le samedi
14 mars e
effectivement moi j'ai eu
un appel
à l'époque du cabinet du premier
ministre pour me dire il ya plusieurs
grands cabinets de conseil qui se sont
manifestés pour aider voilà intel intel
si tu veux tu peux les appeler ils sont
dispo pour faire du pro bono pas pour ça
donc je te le dis sous serment je dis
les choses
à part cela je n'ai je crois jamais reçu
de d'injonction de mai tutelle de faire
appel
à aa
consultant orange j'ai vu quelques
consultant
expliqué qu'
il était très bien en cours avec les
mini ce premier ministre président de la
république etc quand je me souviens d'un
et qui m'arrivera des tas d'ennuis si je
ne faisais plus appel à lui voilà ça
j'ai vu ça c'est des petits cabinets qui
font sa
niche et parcourez et vous avez souligné
que j'étais toujours là mais
deux que mais je n'ai jamais eu de
d'injonctions à
faire appel à lui
[Musique]